let's hear more hey yo Pio this is Matt
from New England Matt from New England
and that's almost British straight-up
nobody ever talks about that [ __ ] so
oh we're I work at a drunk tank all
right and I worked a third drunk tank
like what do you mean like Dave and
Buster's I don't even know what that is
let's hear more heard shift you know the
graveyard shift so I see the craziest of
the crazies so basically last week and I
go in hold on let me look this up drunk
tank is it a prison oh yeah a large
prison cell for the detention of drunks
bang bang well you know who you ain't
you know you ain't taking care of is uh
my boy Jack who's got 75 day sober but
let's hear more meant to my chest to
relieve my coworker and my co-workers
telling me that she had a gentleman
there earlier who was obviously
intoxicated saying that he was in the
Mafia he's been traveling around the
country state state he's been killing
people hmm
so she said she had a man there that was
a self-proclaimed serial killer but dude
that you know what I already I'm like do
they do the good killers say they're
killers yeah it seemed like give you
real good at something you more low-key
about it especially if it is you know
ending other people's existences but
that's just me this year month no and
he's been getting away with it and he's
telling this to my coworker he's well
over the limit he's about to three times
over the limit at this point and she's
like an older woman you know she's
defenseless basically and she's like I
will come back here and find you if you
tell anybody she goes damn it's just
making me mildly erect dude I'm not even
joking I was starting to feel a little
bit of thump done in my dump let's hear
more she goes oh no big deal I'm not a
cop you know I'm not gonna tell anyone
well I come into work and of course she
tells me this I'm like oh you've been
talking to a serial killer for a couple
hours that's great
no and that's the thing every time a
woman feels like they're about to get
serial killed who do they come to men
okay you know everybody wants equal
opportunity but nobody wants to deal
with serial killers themselves we look
if you want to help us then help us at
all times don't just come around ladies
when you want defense from possible
future murder of yourself by someone
else by serial killer help us at all
times or be friends always let's hear
more that's just part of the job a
couple hours later because this guy was
released to a silver party he comes back
so you released an assumed serial killer
this is this is all over the place more
the police bring him back for going to
another bar getting rowdy again so I
have to talk to the serial killer
allegedly he seems like a normal dude
you know so he's brought into it that's
their trick
he ain't gonna being gonna talk to you
and be juggling knives you know and hide
and sighin
you know and you know have a cyanide
recipe on his jacket that's their trick
Matthew is that they don't you're not
supposed to know their serial killers
that's what I'm thinking man if I'm
drunk in a place and there's a there's a
lady there she's the guard or whatever
[ __ ] yeah i'ma tell her I'm a serial
killer what else you gonna do you're
bored probably you used to be in at the
bar having fun more from a police
vehicle and then there's another cop car
behind him is backed up so I this guy
he's been drinking more he's actually
like so over the limit I have to send
him to the hospital
so I said into the hospital and I asked
one of the officers to stay back so I
can talk to him and I tell him what my
coworker told me he's been going around
the country he's been killing people and
I told him that you know he would come
back and harm us if he found out so the
cops at all just look into his criminal
history and you know we'll see where
those in there so once I go back inside
I realize how much of a [ __ ] idiot I
am
now I'm so paranoid I'm having trouble
sleeping I'm looking at the security
camera I'm at work right now I'm looking
at the cameras I'm seeing this car going
up and down the street this red Jeep I
could see that all
do and I don't know what the [ __ ] took
you look I'll tell you what to do man
get your life up okay you out here you
know I love you brother but listen you
first of all you said a senior citizen
lady okay and I respect senior citizens
but a lot of them you know they're just
starting to bother everybody and a
senior citizen lady told you that
there's a killer she met a killer you
know in all first of all all women say
that I'm dating this guy he seems like
he could be a serial killer that's half
the dudes out there we had a guy called
up last week [ __ ] might have killed a
lady and tried to use our episode as an
alibi said he took a lady out she got
wasted he hasn't seen her in two days or
heard from her he has her phone and some
other [ __ ] dude I'm dumb and I know that
that is palpable
probably murder so look man you telling
me and then you scared you got the lady
drunk the man's drinking more you let
the dude go out to drink more and now
you're trying to square off with him and
talk to him
bruh that do might be a murderer let him
sober up and see what he can do y'all
trying to take you guys aren't hanging
back and tailing a drunk how hard is it
the dudes three times over the legal
limit he's in a red Jeep doing go and
we're just going back and forth and
reverse in a parking spot the dudes
[ __ ] up do we have any knives on him
frist that [ __ ] frisk him dude
check him check his ass four blades do
what's going on you know if you are I
couldn't if you were an officer or not
Matt but look ya'll shooting people out
there shoot this dude shoot him he
doesn't seem like he'll even care but
good luck out there dude if you don't
get murdered call us back in two months
and just just leave one voicemail says
hey it's Matt I didn't get murdered good
evening good afternoon and other times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw I mean it was okay but the next
video you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or
watch this one watch this one watch this
one watches one